so it's come to my attention that Donald
Trump doesn't seem to understand how the
federal debt and federal budget deficit
work which probably won't surprise a lot
of people in our audience you might
remember or you might not that a while
ago it really wasn't clear whether Trump
understood the difference between health
insurance and life insurance I don't
know if you remember this but at the
time we covered it Donald Trump said to
the New York Times back when he was
interviewed in July of 2017 quote so
pre-existing conditions are a tough deal
because you're basically saying from the
moment the insurance you're 21 years old
you start working and you're paying 12
bucks a year for insurance and by the
time you're 70 you get a nice plan
here's something where you walk up and
say I want my insurance it's a very
tough deal but it is something that
we're doing a good job of so that is a
description of life insurance what's
called whole life the whole life
policies accrue value over someone's
lifetime and when Trump talks about 12
bucks a year or $1 a month that also is
confusing because that's usually the
price for term life insurance not whole
life insurance which doesn't accrue
value so it was just like completely
whacked out Trump seemed to be talking
about health insurance but he described
whole life by quoting prices typically
associated with term life and the
conclusion I came to was this guy
doesn't have the slightest idea what
he's talking about that gets us to this
weekend it seems that Donald Trump is
confused not only about health insurance
versus life insurance but it seems he
also is confused about the federal
budget deficit versus the trade deficit
which is extraordinarily scary because
Trump ran both on fixing the trade
deficit and the budget deficit he hasn't
done either he's actually made both
worse and he doesn't seem to know the
difference between the two this is
really really weird two times late last
week Donald Trump said something that
was the sort of thing that normally like
an 11 year old who's just starting
middle school might say because they're
only starting to learn the basics about
how the world works Trump was asked
about the federal deficit the federal
budget deficit deficit revenues versus
expenditures surplus versus deficit not
the trade deficit
Trump gave an answer about the trade
deficit and tariffs which has nothing to
do with it I mean just it has absolutely
nothing to do with what Trump was asked
take a look at this well the trade deals
won't kick in for a while you know
number one the USMC hasn't even been
approved yet has to go before Congress
you get approved that she can approve
quickly NAFTA was one of the worst deals
ever made during the campaign I said I
will either terminate NAFTA or negotiate
a new deal and we negotiated a good deal
now if you went back to pre NAFTA that
would be frankly okay with me pre NAFTA
or the New Deal but I won't allow NAFTA
NAFTA was a horrible deal for this
country you look at these scars all over
a country where you go to New England
you go to Ohio you go to Pennsylvania
you see what I mean what happened in
North Carolina you have factories that
are still empty from what happened with
NAFTA NAFTA was a horrible deal the u.s.
MCA is a great deal but pre NAFTA is we
had huge surpluses with Mexico with
NAFTA we have huge deficits we lose a
hundred billion dollars a year on trade
with Mexico does that sound good so
let's be super clear here the answer has
nothing to do with the question Trump
was asked about why is the federal
budget deficit exploding and he says
well some of the tariffs haven't kicked
in u.s. MCA a trade deal hasn't been
signed and aft as a disaster and we used
to have a trade surplus with Mexico the
question was you claimed that all
economic indicators are up yet the u.s.
deficit and debt are going up which is
the opposite direction we want them
going you of course it's relevant
because Trump campaigned on reducing
that and Trump says well the trade
deficit isn't down yet
because some of the deals haven't kicked
in that's not the same deficit Donny boy
so let's give him the benefit of the
doubt why we would at this point I don't
know but give him the benefit of the
doubt imagine that he didn't hear the
question correctly or whatever a few
hours later he's interviewed by the New
York Times and it's the exact same
nonsense again
Trump is asked whether he might keep the
tariffs even if he makes a so-called
good trade deal with China
and he responds quote yes sure we have
25% now on fifty billion dollars and by
the way Peter that's a lot of money
pouring into our treasury you know we
never made five cents with China we're
we're getting right now 25 percent on
fifty billion dollars and then I was
putting 25 percent at a later date which
date came and went
twenty-five percent or two hundred
billion you might not have any idea of
what Trump is talking about there but
again he's talking about tariffs Trump
is talking about tariffs generating
money for the Treasury which figures in
to the federal budget deficit this is
not how it works okay tariffs are paid
by American companies to Chinese
companies if we want their goods for
import now there are if you want to go
by the letter of this there are some
customs duties that can come from
tariffs but they are very small they're
less than 1% of all of the taxes
collected by the Treasury it's basically
a non-factor the Chinese people aren't
paying the tariffs it's whoever imports
the stuff from China that pays the
tariffs meaning mostly American
companies and again Trump is talking
about tariffs as if they're going to
deal with his blown up federal budget
deficit there's a bunch of articles that
notice this and they wrote it's unclear
if Trump understands the budget deficit
it doesn't seem unclear to me it seems
perfectly clear that he doesn't
understand the difference between the
trade deficit and the budget deficit and
you would think Trump would know a lot
about debts and si and his businesses
have had such debt problems but he
doesn't seem to get it and when you
think back and remember this is the guy
who stared directly at a solar eclipse
does anybody think that he is up to date
on the intricacies of revenues versus
expenditures I guess not and it's really
embarrassing and the the the the biggest
problem with this is not that I mean
listen it's it's stunning that the
president doesn't understand this stuff
at this point it's not surprising but
the way in which his followers will
blindly blindly defend him and say they
were trick questions or the transcript
has been doctored or
the video is a deep fake which can't be
trusted or whatever he just doesn't seem
to get it he doesn't seem to know the
difference between life insurance and
health insurance he doesn't seem to know
the difference between the budget
deficit and the trade deficit he just
doesn't know and then it's up to us to
decide whether it's acceptable to have a
president who doesn't know that stuff
you tell me